c'est même la vie de château ici camille
depuis le 9 juillet ce sont les
estivales tous les jours du lundi au
vendredi de 13h30 à 19h sport et détente
sont au rendez vous ok joue la corde
avec mon show nisé et mme jean jé pas
forcément la bonne tenue alors le temps
de me changer
écoutez madame le maire vous vous rendez
compte qu'il y en a pour tous les goûts
à la fois pour les tout-petits petit
dans la zone très sécurisé des communs
du château avec des éléments comptables
et puis vous avez également ici pour un
peu plus grand voire les adultes les
ados et puis aussi des personnes on va
dire les seniors qui viennent pour un
peu de calme bonjour que la mesure
alors qu'est ce que la slackline savent
ateliers d'équilibré où on s'amuse à
faire les funambules en fait j'ai vu des
enfants très doué il peut essayer bien
avec plaisir alors tu vas prendre un
bâton dans chaque main tu vas venir
poser ton pieds bien à plat ce chapitre
est pour cet agent super gti de rester
droite
merci que l'indre et j'imagine qu'au
bout d'un moment on peut vite lâché les
bâtons oui oui oui c'est ça après on
fait lâcher un bâton après on fait
lâcher l'autre on reste toujours un
petit peu à côté puis ceux qui sont
vraiment à l'aise et on les laisse faire
tout seul après ici on est dans le monde
des tout petits dans le monde des tout
petits il ya quatre structures
disponibles selon les âges de quoi
donner de la sécurité pour pouvoir
s'amuser tranquille et je vois quelques
petites choses qui apparemment peuvent
être empruntés voilà par exemple pour
emprunter tout ce qui est ballon et
aussi des cartes comme celui ci par
exemple qui est un casque je peux tester
bien sûr
[Musique]
j'espère que vous aussi vous allez vous
laisser tenter attention les activités
ne seront pas assurées le 3 août et il
n'y a pas que plaisir qui joue le jeu
c'est le cas d'autres communes attrape
par exemple on vous invite à la plage à
la piscine jacquemond quo jusqu'au 14
août avec des semaines à thème du côté
de nos repas direction le café de la
plage deux mois d'activités manuelles
sportives et familiales avec des temps
forts au mois d'août à rambouillet ont
fait durer le plaisir jusqu'au 2
septembre bergerie plage ouvre ses
portes tous les jours à 14 à une plage
de sable une piscine de pâques des
tracteurs à pédales des cahiers de
vacances
impossible bien sûr de citer toutes les
communes mais pour profiter pleinement
de votre été rendez vous sur casque
parce qu'il point fr pour moi l'été a
déjà commencé